I would consider myself
a paleoanthropologist,
so I study humans, but in the past.
We know the fire has been around for a long time,
at least a million years.
The question is, what's been the evolving relationship that humans and
human ancestors have had with fire?
I spent a lot of time surveying
and leading excavations in Malawi,
which is in
Southern Central Africa.
We thought it was going
to tell us something about this
particular time period where we
start to see a really, pretty
substantial increase in the
complexity with which humans,
early humans are making stone
tools and just kind of making different kinds of artifacts.
We knew based on the research
that had been done by our
colleagues in sort of
the geosciences, that there had
been periods of time in the
past when that lake was rising
and falling and at some point
in time, it was basically just gone.
We were thinking, how would that have affected
people on the kind of the broad scale.
Our colleagues, they drilled this massive core down
into the sediments of the lake.
They pulled up all of this mud,
and in the mud is this record
of past vegetation and past fire history,
because there's little bits of charcoal
that end up in the system when there's more burning on the landscape.
They were still busy working
through the majority of their results,
at the same time that we started our archaeological project,
we were working in parallel and sort of overlapping a bit.
And it wasn't really until we had this, kind of one
conversation where we realized
that we were both coming up against the same problem.
We were finding that all of the
archaeological sites that we
were discovering dated to a
very specific time period.
That was all within the last eighty-five thousand years.
They were discovering that they
were finding a lot of evidence
for major ecological turnover
and environmental change that
they couldn't readily explain
using climate variables alone.
And that was also
within the last eighty-five thousand years.
So, it kind of wasn't until
we had a conversation with each other that we knew
that we had complementary data sets that
were really going to tell that story together.
We think a fire often as this
destructive tool.
That doesn't have to be the case, because if
you have the right kind of ecological knowledge
and you know exactly where and when to set the fires,
and how to control them,
what you can actually do is you can shape
the landscape to do your bidding, in a sense.
You can clear out undergrowth strategically
and then you can
make new grass come up
and that draws in all of the animals
that like to hang out in those kinds of habitats,
so you can sort of engineer the world around you.
What we came out with was, I think,
a pretty interesting result.
We were expecting the environment
and climate to have influenced the people,
but really what we found is that it was
people who are influencing their environment.